in the military and in general have you
contemplated your mortality have you
been afraid of death what was what's
your relationship like with death
i was willing to accept
an oversized amount of risk i'll say
when i was younger as an aviator yeah
not not in the jet but just that was my
life you know i felt like i was going to
live forever
um
and going out in the war you know
strangely didn't really change that
because
you know as an aviator again we're
riding up high on our horse up there so
there were times when i was in
situations that could have resulted in
death from from flying or from emergency
in the aircraft but
i'll be honest i never
really kind of sat down to think about
the morale the mortality of it
afterwards i feel like i kind of signed
a check at the beginning and it was my
job to perform as well as i could and if
something happened in that then i better
damn will be sure i would do my best at
the time then
um so you know i i maybe didn't
personally reflect on it as much as of
it i
one would think you know because once
you get in that machine it doesn't give
you a lot of time to sit back and
philosophize on
on your current situation and that same
just like we weren't seeing these or
when we've seen these objects off the
coast we weren't necessarily you know
examining them every day right we'd put
them into that bucket because it wasn't
something that was going to kill us
right away
and thinking about death when you're so
close to it all the time would be
debilitating
it would probably make you worse at your
job it would
well maybe you can think about death
when you look out when you go out into
nature and think like the
the
the fact that this whole ride ends this
is such a weird thing and the the old
makes way to new
and that's all throughout nature and if
you just look at the the cruelty of
nature or the beauty of nature however
you think about it the fact that the the
big thing eats the little thing
over and over
um and that's just how it progresses and
that's how adaptation happens
death is a requirement for
uh evolution
and you know
whether evolution allows us to see
objective reality or not uh it still
gives you some interesting thoughts
about perspectives of death and
especially concerning it's a biological
necessity as far as evolution is
concerned
yeah it's weird it's weird that uh
there's been like a hundred billion
people that lived before us
and that you and i will be forgotten
this whole thing we're doing right now
is meaningless in that sense but at the
same time it feels deeply meaningful
somehow
i guess that that's the question i want
to ask when you go out to nature
with family
what do you think is the meaning of it
all what's the meaning of life
or maybe when you put on the night
goggles the the night vision goggles and
look up at the stars
why we're here
i can't speak for everyone but
at least the way i interpret it
you know or at least i i feel like i
interpret my way here my job is i feel
like my role is just to be
curious about the environment in a
manner that allows us to understand as
much as possible
i think that the human mind
whether it's just the mass inside our
skull or you know whether there's some
type of quantum interactions going on
her mind is an incredible has incredible
ability to output new information
in in a universe that
you know somewhat stale of information
right um our minds are in some somewhat
unique in that we can imagine and
perceive things that could never ever
have possibly naturally occurred and yet
we can make it happen we can
substantiate that with enough belief
that it's true and it can happen
and so for me
i feel like i just need to encourage
that to encourage you know interaction
with reality such that it leads us to
newer and grander you know interactions
with this universe
and all that starts with a little bit of
curiosity exactly
right you're an incredible person uh
you've done so many things and there's
so much still
still ahead of you thank you for being
brave enough to talk about ufos
um and doing it so seriously and thank
you for pushing forward on all these
fronts in terms of technology so from
um just the fighter jets the the
engineering of that
to the aiml applications in the combat
setting that's super interesting and
then now quantum
i can't wait to see to see what you do
next thank you so much for sitting down
and talking today it was an honor it was
my pleasure thank you lex
you